there's a lot of Islamophobia out there
and people are scared they see you maybe
you fly and you get hassled at the
airport a lot of people do because
they're trying to practice this this
peer way of life peer monotheism not
trying to harm anybody being a benefit
to society and I'm sure you've been
asked this have you people thinking now
that you've accepted the other and they
equate you in Islam with terrorism what
would you say well I mean I would just
tell them that you know Islam is a
gigantic tree right i mean there's
almost some say close to two billion
people on earth and out of that tree we
have bad apples we have our mentally ill
we have our misguided and ultimately
muslims are not angels we weren't
created to be perfect and so we do sin
and we do have people who do a lot of
bad things and we are a huge tree so
sometimes it appears that many of us are
doing bad things but the reality of it
is I would highly recommend anyone who
has these kind of suspicions of Muslims
to actually get to know and that's why I
teach the massage the the Muslim houses
of worship all over this country
whenever I'm able to do something like
meet your Muslim neighbor which is to
invite your neighborhood to come and
meet you and sit down and eat a meal
with you and you'll find that those
misconceptions will dissipate very
quickly